[Musik]
ich kann sie flüstern die patente auf
den gedankengängen des patentamts sie
erzählen geschichten von geistesblitzen
geniestreichen gehirnschmalz von ideen
die die welt veränderten erfindungen die
die forschung revolutionierten
innovation als inspiration für noch mehr
innovation jede idee jeder erfindung
zieht ja weitere erfindungen nach sich
denken sie an den übergang von einer
kutsche zum automobil
jetzt sind wir dabei da den nächsten
innovations- schritt zu machen dass
alternative antriebe gesucht werden
und wir werden das erleben wenn die
elektroautos auf der straße fahren mit
akku betrieben mit brennstoffzelle
betrieben dass diese antriebe dann auch
weiterentwickelt werden und so wie der
neue erfindung nach sich ziehen
aber nicht alle patienten wurden zur
erfolgsgeschichte mit manchen ließ sich
kein geld verdienen andere überholte der
fortschritt und wieder andere sollten
nur die forschung der konkurrenz
blockieren abgestempelt alleingelassen
legen sie jetzt hier herum
jahrzehntelang und seit sieben jahren
auch ep 16 25 15
dieses patent zum beispiel gehört der
deutschen telekom
es geht dabei um ein verfahren zur
nutzung von ortungsdaten bestimmt eine
gute idee aber das unternehmen nutzt sie
nicht
heißt das jetzt dass das die endstation
ist für dieses patent oder bekommt dass
doch noch eine zweite chance
es gibt patente die brauchen diese
zweite chance dann vielleicht sogar eine
dritte und vierte chance zum pohlmann
hat ein herz für ungenutzte patienten
klar
schließlich verdiente bedienen sein geld
sein starter bei politics nimmt alle
patienten abgenutzt oder umgenutzt
speist sie in eine riesige datenbank und
visualisiert sie und die kunden zahlen
dafür hier etwa die patentanmeldung von
google microsoft und apple im vergleich
aber können wir unternehmen so was nicht
selbst machen
es geht immer mehr darum patente zu
verstehen wie messen fast hunderttausend
neue weltweite patent anmeldung im monat
und die kann keiner mehr lesen dafür
braucht man eine software die diese
patente intelligent aus liest versteht
was innerlich in den patenten steht und
dann aber auch feststellen kann ist das
eigentlich relevant ist es wertvoll das
wollen vor allem kunden aus
forschungsintensiven branchen etwa
it-unternehmen mit pohlmanns
datenanalyse können sie die erfindung
der konkurrenz im blick behalten und sie
können die ungenutzten patente aus dem
eigenen haus wieder finden
die können sie dann entweder verkaufen
oder lizensieren gibt es also doch noch
hoffnung für unser bislang ungenutztes
patent befinden es auf der plattform von
ip latics aufgrund dieser information
diesen wirklichen inhalt des patentes
berechnet jetzt das tool ob es in dem
bereich ähnliche andere patente gibt ob
sich da unternehmen tone tummeln die in
dem bereich auch schon was machen wir
das sind natürlich jetzt meine
potenziellen käufer unser patent ist
eine technologie die standort daten
auswertet und daraus vorhersagen trifft
das wäre auch was für game designer die
wissen wollen wo spieler sich hinbewegen
oder automobilunternehmen die an
selbstfahrenden autos forschen und
fahrtziele berechnen
das ist natürlich ein positives signal
dass ich jetzt verstehen kann ok in
einen der branche könnte ich das patent
platzieren
ich könnte es lizensieren an die
relevanten unternehmen und könnte damit
das patent dem patent die zweite chance
geben ist weiterzukommen
kommerzialisieren kommt doch noch groß
raus kommt doch noch groß raus
vielleicht anders als der erfinder sich
das je vorgestellt hat aber es bekommt
vielleicht eine ganz andere anwendung
162 5 415 hofft also auf eine zweite
chance
und die verspricht im pullman auch einen
anderen ungenutzten patenten
vielleicht finden sie also doch noch aus
dem patentamt in unseren alltag eine
gute idee bleibt eine gute idee
man muss sie nur festhalten